ah
[Música]
y
respóndame en la siguiente pregunta
de qué color es esto
ok ahora un poco más duro de qué color
es esto
y qué color es esto
que toma la vaca
y pensar que así andamos en la vida
en automático
andar en automático no nos deja sentir
esas sensaciones ni percibir mejor y ni
imaginarnos ser felices pero no es culpa
de nosotros así lo aprendimos a ir todo
deprisa todo rápido con anestesia unas
cosas sin anestesia es otra y al final
un vacío existencial un vacío que muchas
mujeres pretenden llenar con la
maternidad la divina
tampoco parece que son felices yo soy
mamá soy mamá de 33 varoncitos preciosos
uno de tres años uno de cinco y uno de
mi esposa sí
y ahí me causa mucha curiosidad cuando
mi suegra me dice cariño
vaya vaya
mira como tienes esta casa desordenada
yo me rindo no te ayudo más mira esto
pongo los zapatos aquí los desaparecen y
yo le digo se grita
no hablemos de crianza
que yo aquí tengo el hijo to you tube el
otro criando
ser mamá es afeitarse una pierna un
domingo y la otra un jueves
ya sabes más o menos qué es ser mamá no
hay un concepto literal insiste el
diccionario en decir que es una
experiencia y una experiencia es algo
que cada quien vive a su ritmo ya su
forma gracias a diccionario
es algo indescriptible la maternidad yo
recuerdo cuando estaba dando teta que
ahí me preguntaban
y te sale leche
no es que quieres que me salga pues
agua de coco
roncito
haya horchata
claro que me sale leche
entonces es completamente indescriptible
lo que es la maternidad ya que estamos
en confianza que creen ustedes que
preferimos las mamás digan la verdad ya
saben cómo responder fuerte claro comer
caliente o dormir
afeitarnos la otra pierna o dormir
tener sexo salvaje o dormir
eso no se lo voy a decir
bien ya sabes entonces que la maternidad
te queda claro ahora vamos con el humor
porque indistintamente que seas mamá o
papá o ser vivo
yo quiero que tú que tú vivas tu
maternidad con tu paternidad con tu amor
tu trabajo con amor y tu vida con humor
y para eso te voy a aclarar algunos
términos de forma rápida que tú puedas
identificar y los puedas poner a tu
favor
el primero es la sonrisa que es la
sonrisa es esto es lo gesticular es esa
cuando pelas los dientes lo que es la
sonrisa yo lo aplico mucho cuando estoy
en un centro comercial
y viene mi ex novio
si con su nueva novia que no ha parido
que está más buena que yo y que tú
juntas
y mis hijos están con un perrinche
acabando con la tienda
justo ahí hago
es la misma que tú le pones a tu jefe oa
la de la nómina
exacto la otra es la risa la risa es
cuando a estas sonrisas se le une un
sonido es decir pasas de a
esto es genuino y es espontáneo nos
podemos reír incluso de algo que nos
cause nervios va y lo otro
específicamente la carcajada está que no
para no para nunca no para nunca todos
tenemos un amigo que se ríe como
cochinito baja
y finalmente el chiste el chiste es una
estructura narrativa corta y ocurrente
que lo que busca es que tú te rías
siempre tenemos un amigo que ha hecho
chistes malos pero bueno la sea su mayor
intento ok para que te digo esto porque
muchas personas relacionan la risa a la
sonrisa la carcajada y el chiste
con buen humor
y realmente no es así
y otras personas dicen es que estás
tapando con él con la risa tu tristeza
tampoco es así yo puede estar convencido
de tener la mejor sonrisa del mundo y
tener una depresión pero también estar
feliz y disfrutar de la vida o no
ahora
porque hablo del humor y la maternidad
que ese entonces el humor
el humor es la forma de reaccionar ante
diferentes impulsos
pre dispositiva mente o negativamente
pero la idea es que tú lo hagas positivo
ok ya vimos que todo esto se relaciona
entonces con el buen humor
entonces el humor es la forma de
reaccionar ante diferentes impulsos y la
maternidad que es algo indescriptible y
tiene muchísimos impulsos por ejemplo
cuando sales embarazadas
impulso nombrar guano
cuando te enteras que estás embarazada
que no es lo mismo
el embarazo
esa paz del calor ok el nacimiento bien
sea parto o cesárea
la lactancia la crianza el marido la
suegra mi mamá
todo eso junto y si las maestras
porque yo no sé ustedes pero nosotros
aprendimos tú y yo con el método de mamá
mi mono barrer y roe lal el hilo luz
para aprender a leer y escribir ahora
los niños exprés aprenden por fonética
es decir que para decir el yo tengo que
decir
y para decir esto que sí
[Música]
y padecí h
entonces se podría imaginar yo a las
tres de la tarde con seis tareas
pendientes de mi hijo a 52 grados de
sensación térmica y mérida yucatán y mi
hijo me dice mami como se escribe fuego
y yo le digo apunta
o
e
y mamá app
y es justo en este momento cuando yo
necesito arropar a la maternidad de
abrazarme a la maternidad
porque si no me quedo sin enseñarle a mi
hijo o mucho peor sin ser su ejemplo
a ver cómo son las mamás alrededor del
mundo porque yo no creo que yo soy la
única extraña como creen ustedes que son
las argentinas por ejemplo
típica de la minita te puedes lastimar
mi amor
bájate mi vida no lo digo más
letizia
cálmate
como son las mamás colombianas esa mamá
todas sexy porque los colombianos son
sexys entonces ya van a empezar a ver
juan diego y catalina dejen el jueguito
pues ya aquí
guardo tráiganme el pan solo yo
como son las mamás españolas
jerónimo gerardo si mauricio quedarnos
quietos me vais a ver
hola amiguitas
y las mamás cubanas oyen ahora creo que
yo soy cuba
mucho cuidado a mamás cubanas o sean
beto tablet
mucho cuidado o sea tú no me conoces
y mi mamá como es mi mamá
esa que me acurruqué en sus brazos que
dijo que me amaba desde el primer
momento de su vida
- de mi vida
cuento atrás y lleva una baja tez
aunque también esta cosa más
yo hasta los 4 años pensé que me llamaba
[ __ ]
como yo baja de [ __ ] súbete [ __ ] en caña
muévete
[Aplausos]
hasta que me metieron en la escuela
y me dijeron bienvenida karely y yo
carell
qué nombre tan precioso de quién es ese
y mi mamá tuyo [ __ ]
a ti también te llamaron [ __ ] lo sé
que siente tu cuerpo en este momento
como un cosquilleo rico
así que tienes que sentir todo el tiempo
así es esto es lo que yo quiero para
todas las mamás del mundo y para ti
también entonces esta sensación que pasa
que estás en que ocurre químicamente en
tu cuerpo está liberando endorfinas está
oxigenando tu cerebro tu sangre ya está
corriendo más rápidamente se está
nutriendo de ti y tú de ellas
y entonces que nos hace que nos
paralicemos y no vivamos estos días días
ya no estamos en automático aquí ya
estábamos en placer tú estás en placer
ya que quería llegar
estar en placer nos permite cumplir con
la primera ley de box bike que dice que
el aprendizaje es completamente
direccional es completamente
proporcional a la diversión que se tiene
entonces si nos divertimos cuando
bailamos y aprendemos a bailar si nos
divertimos comer y decimos guau si me
gusta esta comida y la sigo comiendo
aprenderemos a hacer mamás
sí mientras lo decidas si mientras lo
elijas
mientras te dispongas a vivirla con
humor la maternidad con humor entonces
es la fusión de esto indescriptible pero
real con la forma entretenida positiva
responsable consciente
del humor de esa experiencia única de
ser mamá
durante más de tres años he podido ver
como mamás alrededor del mundo han
cambiado su vida con la maternidad con
humor como están dispuestas a cambiarlo
todo por ser ellas felices para ser
felices a sus hijos
para eso te voy a enseñar solamente dos
técnicas que quiero que te las lleves a
tu casa y quiero que las guardas para ti
y lo apliques a cada persona que puedas
encontrar sobre todo para ti y la
primera es el sí
acepta y propones esta técnica es
maravillosa y es extraída de la
improvisación teatral cuando tú aceptas
es como si tuviese en blanco acepta la
maternidad y propone algo acepta tu
trabajo propone algo acepta tu vida
propone algo
el sí y por ejemplo lo aplico mucho con
mi esposo cuando él me dice mi amor
vamos al cine sí y como me cuida los
niños
y helio mejorado es una de mis prácticas
favoritas extraídas del coaching
adaptada a la maternidad y efectivamente
es cuando trato que mostrar físicamente
ok la hace esto en tu casa y es como son
las personas tristes
mete las nalgas
si nació sin nada ya nació triste
me está en los hombros
con su cara así así no se puede vivir
por la vida como son esas mamás molestas
todas las sabemos
mandíbula te miran profundo
de lanza la chancla
como son las mamás felices
levanta el athletic a las que le dejó la
maternidad
si está lactando es una más grande que
la otra
pone sus hombros hacia atrás cabeza 90
grados saca las pompas tú también lo
puedes hacer
y levanta tu mano y la sonrisa tal cual
de presentadora de televisión
[Música]
esta cuerda
cuando viaja tu suegra hallaba a la de
la nómina
y así vas por favor baja tu mano para
que no crea que estás tan locas
vivir la maternidad con humor me ha
permitido darte está en paz
tener a mis hijos reconstruir toda mi
vida creer en dios
y saber que estoy cumpliendo con mi
mayor propósito en la vida que es
enseñar a todas y cada una de las mamás
del mundo hacer una maternidad libre a
la medida de cada una de ellas una
maternidad perfecta e ideal para ella y
su familia
esta maternidad también me permitió
emigrar vivir con gente nueva
lanzarme al vacío conocer nuevos lugares
ser plena y ser tal cual como soy
reírme de mí misma y de cada episodio de
mi maternidad es sin duda alguna una
feliz y placentera forma de vivir y ser
mamá muchas gracias
[Aplausos]